this morning on the dish when we dine at
a fine restaurant we don't often see the
hard work that goes into preparing each
and every dish nor the struggles that
brought the chef to where they are today
but in washington d.c ashish alfred
wants to share his story a story of
overcoming personal demons to become a
star of the capital area's culinary
scene we met up with him at duck duck
goose his acclaimed take on the french
brasserie
this is a beautiful spot in a city
growing an impressive restaurant scene
right right in the middle of it
alfred's duck duck goose flips the
script on classic french dining
and so the feeling of duck duck goose is
is
casual comfy fun
memorable but sophisticated but
sophisticated we sat down for a tasting
cheers cheers
what i would want somebody to cook for
me if i was having my last supper i'm a
big fan of roast chicken can i carve
some food
thank you so much
thank you super healthy without giving
you a little bit of sauce wait wait wait
wait just a touch
i'm gonna give you a little potato
because what's chicken without a potato
oh my gosh there you are so this isn't
just a potato no no it's a pomena and
you shave them on a mandolin and then
you cook in a little bit of clarified
butter then you bake it and you flip it
and you bake it some more there's his
twist on broccolini beet salad
asparagus and annulati so it's filled
with peas there's a little bit of butter
there's a little bit of oil
good
your face does good see what you're
doing right now is what we live for as
restaurants that moment when somebody
puts something in their mouth and they
go quiet and they have nothing left to
say i seized i'm about to cry
i'm not kidding you thank you in the
kitchen alfred treated me to a french
cooking lesson we're making scallops
we're making scallops
one more
i'm ready for this
and now the hardest part in the world
for people what do you think that is
turn it over just to leave them alone ah
there you go now use the edge of the pan
to scrape it off
good job
beautiful flip it over
perfect
that's what i want to hear
beauty full
hello
all of this might seem effortless you're
doing really well i mean i'm over here
handling my hips just chilling but
alfred's journey here was a hard one i
think it's beautiful as a kid he
contended with his dad's alcoholism
bullies at school and sexual abuse he
struggled with his own alcohol and drug
addiction through his teens culinary
school and the early days of his first
restaurant
i
failed in that restaurant and almost
lost my life because of my ego so then
when i got sober and came back i started
building these businesses that did not
revolve around my ego i started building
businesses that revolved around the
clients coming in the door and the
people coming into work and it was funny
how the business changed then it wasn't
about me anymore but as far as the path
of addiction
i almost died everybody knows the story
i fell out in the street busted my face
open spit out my teeth
um
my mother showed up at my house a couple
days later and
for a woman that had never written me
off no matter what i had done
she told me you want nothing to do with
you
unless you do something different more
than seven years later he remained sober
now the sole proprietor of four
celebrated eateries
these days alfred gets his rush from
daily workouts proudly posted on social
media and when feeling a bit jittery
he resorts to push-ups
i couldn't resist the challenge
but his methods reset a tone for an
industry with one of the highest rates
of alcohol and drug abuse and how did
you change it how did i change it here
started with myself and i decided what i
was and wasn't going to tolerate in my
buildings we're dry houses you don't
drink at work
my managers aren't taking the staff out
to drink after work so when they tip out
they get it on a check they have to go
deposited in a bank just small things to
create accountability and i think so
many people are
afraid ashamed
and
i think that if nothing else that these
restaurants have done for me helped
allow me to be a voice for people that
wouldn't feel uncomfortable normally
sharing about their own struggles
whether it was sexual abuse whether it's
addiction whether it's whatever
you know there's no shame in any of it
alongside his signature cocktails each
of alfred's restaurants offers up a full
menu
of non-alcoholic mocktails
light airy for dessert we needed to try
pavlova
[Laughter]
i heard you say on an episode recently
that you had the best bread pudding
you've ever had it was pretty darn good
and it was i gotta cut you off you have
not had our bread pudding
so we went back to the kitchen to try it
straight from the oven
the mouthful
and hug says it all for this guy walking
the straight and narrow doesn't mean
he'll ever stop pushing the envelope
what is next for you boo dinner
no
i'm working on a book
[Applause]
uh i've worked every job in the
restaurant business i believe that each
one of those jobs has taught me a
separate life lesson i'd like to share
that with the world seeing this
restaurant full people packed in having
dinner enjoying themselves kind of
tapping their foot to the music it made
it feel like the world was getting back
to normal
yeah he's so impressive in so many ways
but really loved how he takes those
small practical
uh measures to to help folks along on
his staff
and folks who are you know on the
general public who come to eat his
restaurants at the age thinking about
speaking of which we have a lot of food
here we have the
chicken the beet salad we have two
amazing desserts the pavlova the bread
pudding my favorite is the annulati
un
that's what's in front of us right now
ah take a bite take a bite it is so
worth it
i was gonna say at the age of 31 he's
already lived like two lifetimes yes he
has it's wild
and you know what he's so grateful it's
amazing
his mother basically writing him off the
difference that that made too in his
life not giving up all right we will be
right back
oh these peas are unbelievable
i want to get some of this other stuff
over here now
yeah it's it's so interesting how
really he's taken one um form of
addiction and turned it into another see
such
an incredible workout you know
a more positive absolutely say right but
he puts it into not only you know
working out but he puts it into his food
and his resiliency think about it four
restaurants and he owns all four of them
himself not like
do you know a huge uh
fund or involved in that can we though
do an analysis of your push-up
[Laughter]
um because i'm not sure
that you did quite it was full
i mean the eating was great you the
scallop your scallops were wonderful
that's why i will say that you did a
tremendous job with it i gave you a lot
better getting down in a dress to do the
push-ups well you know
it kind of egged me on it was we didn't
have cameras on at the time and that was
like and then of course the camera of
course like that would be videos yeah it
was like the cameras came on like the
video cameras with the on the on the
phone the phones came out and
he i just the two of us had so much fun
that was really what i take away from
him he
has such a zest for life and it's just a
fun guy and loves what he does which is
so obvious he has found his joy yeah he
has found his joy love it love it